>>> WELCOME TO THE SHOW.
WELCOME TO THE SHOW.
WE'RE BACK.
LET'S GET STRAIGHT TO IT.
LET'S GET TO THE NITTY-GRITTY.
WE'RE BACK AFTER LAST WEEK.
THE PARLAY TRENDED IN A
DIRECTION THAT WE DID NOT WANT
IT TO GO, BUT THAT'S OKAY.
THAT'S WHY WE'RE BACK AND I'M
BLAMING IT ON RYAN.
THAT'S HOW I FEEL.
>> FOR THE REAL ONES IN HERE
THAT REMEMBER, REMEMBER THAT WE
CLOSED THE SHOW SAYING IT IS
GONNA HIT BECAUSE RYAN HAD
NOTHING TO DO WITH IT.
WHETHER I DID OR DID NOT DROP
JAYSON TATUM'S POINTS, IT DIDN'T
MATTER.
IT WAS SIX LEGS AND SEVEN DIDN'T
HIT.
>> I DON'T KNOW.
IT SEEMS LIKE THAT SHOULD MATTER
TO ME.
>> YEAH.
I'M NOT GONNA LIE, RYAN.
YOUR LEG --
>> IT WAS NOT THE VIBE.
>> IT WAS NOT IT.
ROBERT WILLIAMS WAS ALSO AT THE
BOTTOM.
>> I WAS TELLING YOU ALL I
DIDN'T WANT THAT.
>> OH, THIS GUY CALLS ME THE I
TOLD YOU SO GUY, AND THEN HE
SAYS I DIDN'T WANT IT.
>> I'M JUST SAYING, I WAS TRYING
TO GIVE YOU THE HEADS UP.
SPEAKING OF THE CELTICS, THEY'RE
BACK.
>> AND WE SAID IN OUR PRIVATE
SLACK CHANNEL THAT WE'RE GONNA
FADE THE CELTICS FROM NOW ON.
SURE ENOUGH, BOOM, HERE THEY GO.
NBA FINALS REMATCH.
NOW WHAT?
>> NOW WHAT?
WELL, WE TAKE THE CELTICS MINUS
6 AND A HALF, RIGHT?
>> ABSOLUTELY NOT.
SEE, THIS IS WHAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT.
>> WHY NOT?
THE NATIONAL TV CELTICS, THE
ST-RBGS -- THE TNT CELTICS, NOT
THE OTHER CELTICS, THE TNT
CELTICS KILL IT.
THEY'RE FANTASTIC.
>> NO, NO.
>> I'M NOT GONNA LIE, 6 AND A
HALF IS VERY ENTICING TONIGHT.
>> I SAW A STAT THE WARRIORS ARE
5-1 AGAINST THE SPREAD VERSUS
THE CELTICS IN THE LAST SIX.
THAT WOULD SUPPORT YOU.
WHAT SAY YOU, RYAN?
>> WELL, I MEAN, YOU'RE
INCLUDING THE FINALS, CORRECT?
>> YEAH.
>> WHOA, WOULD YOU -- WHOA,
WHOA, WHOA.
>> THIS GAME DOESN'T MATTER AND
CELTICS WILL PROBABLY WIN IT.
>> GIVE ME THE THREE BUCKS.
I NEED THE THREE BUCKS BECAUSE
WE HAVE TO* DO THIS RIGHT.
WE HAVE TO DO THIS RIGHT.
WELCOME TO THE SHOW, EVERYBODY.
WELCOME TO THE SHOW.
MY NAME IS GREG IVORY AND THE
GUY NEXT TO ME I CALL MB.
YOU MAY KNOW HIM AS MICHAEL
BOLEN, BUT HE IS THE BLEACHER
REPORT APP WHISPERER.
AND NEXT TO HIM --
>> DO IT.
>> GO BACK TO THE OTHER SCREEN.
PRODUCER RYAN, WE GOT BEEF.
WE GOT A LITTLE BEEF THIS WEEK,
BRO.
>> WE ALWAYS GOT BEEF.
>> IT'S A LITTLE -- IT'S A
LITTLE EXTRA THIS WEEK.
YOU KNOW, MY TEAMS ARE PLAYING
YOUR TEAMS.
THE BEEF IS REAL THIS WEEK WITH
ME AND RYAN.
IF THEY'RE EVEN CAL EMOJIS, BUT
BEEF IN THE COMMENT BECAUSE THE
BEEF IS REAL.
>> I'M SURE THERE IS STEAK
EMOJIS.
WE HAVE A RATTY MOW -- A RATTY
MOW JOE THOUGH, SO THAT'S NOT
GOING TO CHANGE.
>> I SEE MY BOY AND ASKING IF
WE'RE USING THE FAN DUAL
TONIGHT, AND 100% YES.
YOU KNOW WHAT TIME IT IS.
>> DO YOU SEE THE EMOJI ON THE
SCREEN?
>> UH-OH.
>> I SEE THAT.
>> WHERE'S THE BEEF?
PUT THE BEEF UP THERE BECAUSE IT
IS BEEF BETWEEN ME AND RYAN.
RYAN, LAST WEEK WE ALREADY SAID
YOU RUINED THE PARLAY, BUT YOU
ARE TRYING TO SAY YOU GET IT.
IT'S TIME TO COOK UP ANOTHER
ONE.
IT IS TIME TO COOK UP ANOTHER
DROP YOUR BEST BET FOR TONIGHT'S
TNT GAMES.
WE SAID TNT GAMES ONLY.
IN THE CHAT AND THAT'S WARRIORS
AND CELTICS AND NETS AND SUNS.
RYAN, WHAT ARE THE PEOPLE IN THE
COMMENTS TALKING ABOUT?
>> OUTSIDE OF TKROPB -- DROPPING
STEAK EMOJIS AND RAT EMOJIS, IT
SAYS JORDAN POOL OVER 19 AND A
HALF POINTS.
WE'VE GOT -- AM I SEEING?
I THINK I SEE SCOTTIE BARNES.
GUESS WHAT.
HE IS NOT PLAYING ON TNT
TONIGHT.
RSJ SAYS MONEYLINE UH LOCK.
GREG IS NOT LETTING ME DO IT SO
IT WILL BE A BATTLE FOR THE WIN.
JUST BEING HONEST.
BUDDHA 600 AND TATUM 30.
I DON'T KNOW IF I LIKE THAT.
YOU CAN CONVINCE ME MORE ON
THAT.
AND THEN WEEK PORTER ANDREW
WIGGINS OVER 14 AND A HALF
POINTS.
I SAY WE GO TATUM 2 PLUS 3'S OR
WIGGINS OVER 14 AND A HALF
POINTS.
I DON'T KNOW HOW YOU FEEL GREG.
>> YOU ARE NOT EVEN GOING TO
READ OUT MY GUY DARRIAN GIVING
ME PROPS TODAY?
WOW.
>> WHOA, WHOA, WHOA.
>> ALL RIGHT! I'M SCROLLING UP.
YOU ARE LOOKING DOWN.
THAT IS THE PROBLEM.
>> HEY, RYAN.
>> WHAT?
>> SCOOP ALERT.
I DON'T KNOW IF THIS IS TRUE.
IS JORDAN POOL'S ASSIST NUMBERS
AT TWO AND A HALF?
>> IT MIGHT BE.
THEY ARE USUALLY LOW.
YOU KNOW JORDAN, HE DOESN'T LIKE
TO PASS.
>> STOP IT.
>> I THINK POOL ASSISTS WAS IN
OUR FIRST.
>> YEAH.
>> EASILY.
IS HE NOT UP THERE?
>> NO.
WHY?
>> WOW.
>> THAT MEANS THEY DON'T WANT US
TO VOTE IT.
I AM INTRIGUED BY JORDAN POOL.
HE IS PLAYING REALLY WELL.
STEPH COMING BACK OPENS UP STUFF
WHEN HE IS ON THE FLOOR
TOGETHER.
WE SHOULD MAYBE START WITH 20
POINTS FOR JORDAN POOL.
>> I SAW THAT IN THE CHAT TOO.
TWO DIFFERENT PEOPLE SAID THAT.
AS A WARRIOR FAN -- AS A WARRIOR
FAN JORDAN POOL IS INCONSISTENT.
HE IS VERY GOOD.
HE IS A VERY, VERY GOOD
PROSPECT, BUT THE CONSISTENCY
ISN'T THERE YET.
NOW FACING THIS BOSTON TEAM WHO
IS A DEFENSIVE TEAM, THEY ARE
GONNA SLOW IT DOWN AND I DON'T
WANT TO TALK US OUT OF IT, BUT
WE ARE SKEPTICAL.
>> WE DON'T HAVE TO START THERE.
THAT'S ONE OF THE KNOCKS ON HIM.
HE CAN GO 40 ONE NIGHT AND THEN
TWO OF 10 FROM THREE.
NOT A BAD HANDICAP.
I THINK YOU ARE IN A SPOT THAT
YOU WATCH THIS A LITTLE MORE
THAN I DO.
I'M INTERESTED.
WE CAN FIND THE ASSIST.
I DO THINK HE WILL MAKE AN
IMPACT.
>> IF IT IS SNOT -- IF IT IS
NOT, WE CAN UNDERSTAND WHY IT IS
NOT.
IT IS EASY MONEY.
>> I SEE GREEN OVER 6 AND A HALF
REBOUNDS.
>> YOU TOOK THE WORDS RIGHT OUT
OF MY MOUTH.
I JUST SAW THAT.
DRAYMOND GREEN OVER 6 AND A
HALF.
>> AND I HAVE SOME DATA UP
SAYING HE HAS HIT THAT IN SEVEN
OF THE LAST 10.
>> IT IS PLUS MONEY.
IT IS PLUS MONEY.
>> RIGHT.
>> YOU DON'T WANT TO TEASE IT
DOWN TO 6?
>> HERE IS THE AGE OLD QUESTION
RYAN HAS TO ANSWER.
SHOULD WE TEASE IT DOWN TO 6?
>> IT IS PLUS MONEY.
>> I THINK WE LET IT GO.
I THINK WE LET IT RIDE.
>> I THINK WE LET IT RIDE TOO.
IT IS PLUS MONEY.
HE IS GOING TO BE LOOKING FOR
CLAY.
STEPH A LOT.
A LOT.
>> WE'LL START THERE.
>> A -- WAIT, ARE WE TALKING
ASSISTS ORIE BOUNDS?
I -- OR REBOUNDS.
I THOUGHT WE WERE TALKING
REBOUNDS.
I THINK I SAW OVER 6.5 REBOUNDS.
>> ASSISTS TOO.
>> WE'LL DO REBOUND HAD.
WE'LL DO REBOUNDS.
SIX AND A HALF REBOUNDS.
I CAN GET BEHIND THIS.
>> I LIKE THE REBOUNDS.
ASSISTS TOO THOUGH.
JUST SAYING.
>> NO.
IT IS NOT GOING TO BE THE
DRAYMOND GREEN PARLAY.
>> ALL RIGHT.
AND MARCUS DOWN, WHEN HE GETS
SIX AND A HALF ASSISTS I WANT IT
TO BE CLICKED ON.
>> WHAT ARE WE DOING?
>> ISN'T THAT WHAT YOU LIKE TO
DO?
THROW THINGS IN OUR FACES?
>> WE WE HAVEN'T HIT A PARLAY IN
SUCH A LONGTIME.
>> BECAUSE OF YOU.
>> WELL, THAT'S DEBATABLE.
>> JUST TO BE FAIR --
>> JUST TO BE HONEST --
>> I WALKED INTO THAT ONE.
WE'RE GONG GNAW MOVE -- WE'RE
GONNA MOVE ON HERE.
>> I LIKE MAR -- MARCUS SMART.
MARCUS SMART PLAYS WELL AGAINST
THE WARRIORS.
THIS IS ME PROMPTING MARCUS
SMART PLAYS.
WE ARE GONNA NEED SOME OF THAT.
>> THE MOST RECENT I SEE IS D
HEY -- D HARRIS SAYING THEY ARE
NOT GETTING THAT WITH BOSTON'S
DEFENSE.
HE IS TALKING ABOUT THE
ASSISTS.
I THINK THAT'S A DIFFERENT
STORY.
I THINK THE BOARDS HAVE NOTHING
TO DO WITH THEIR DEFENSE.
I THINK THERE IS GOING TO BE A
CLOSE GAME NBA FINALS-WISE AND
THERE WILL BE AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
ASSISTS, ORIE BOUNDS -- OR
REBOUNDS.
>> THEY SAY DRAMOND IS ON THE DO
NOT BEST LIST.
>> HE IS ON A LOT OF PEOPLE'S DO
NOT BET LIST.
>> AND WE CAN'T HATE THAT.
WE SAID THE BOSTON CELTICS TEAM
IS ON THE DO NOT BET LIST AND
HERE WE ARE.
>> ALL RIGHT, GUYS.
YOU MAY LIKE THIS ONE.
HOW CAN WE NOT TAKE TATUM
PLAYING AT HOME?
HE DOMINATES THE WARRIORS.
NO ONE CAN GUARD HIM ON THE
TEAM.
I'LL BE HONEST.
>> HERE IS THE THING WITH TATUM.
I TEND TO AGREE AND I THINK HE
IS REALLY, REALLY GOOD ON THIS
TEAM.
I THINK HIS POINTS OVER IS,
WHAT, 30, 31 MAYBE.
I MAY BE DOWN TO LOOKING -- TO
LOCKING IN THE THREE'S IF IT IS
OVER ONE AND A HALF.
>> IT IS THREE AND A HALF HERE.
>> OH, WE ARE NOT DOING THAT.
>> SOMEBODY SAID MARCUS 1, 3, 5
ASSIST.
I WOULD BE VERY OKAY WITH MAR --
WITH MARCUS OVER ONE AND A HALF
3'S.
>> I TRUST YOU.
HE PUTS THEM UP.
>> HE DOES PUT THEM UP.
>> IT IS A GOOD PLAY IN MY
OPINION.
>> I LIKE ONE.
WHAT IS ONE?
>> ONE IS GOING TO BE LIKE MINUS
25,000.
>> IS IT?
>> NO.
BUT YOU GET THE POINT.
WE ARE ALREADY IN PLUS MONEY
TERRITORY.
>> YEAH.
THE THING I KNOW ABOUT MARCUS
SMART IS THESE ARE THE GAMES AS
LONG AS HE DOESN'T LOSE HIS MIND
AND GETS A TECH, HE GETS UP FOR
THE GAMES.
I CAN SEE HIM HITTING THIS OVER
AND LIKE THE SECOND QUARTER.
>> I AGREE.
I KNOW SPORTS 27 WANTS US TO
LOOK INTO JORDAN POOLE 3'S.
THE LAST TIME WE DID THIS IT WAS
ONE THE ONLY ONE'S THAT DIDN'T
HIT.
YOU DID.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU.
SHOUT OUT TO ME FOR HUMILITY.
SHOUT OUT ME.
>> SHOUT OUT ME IS INSANE.
>> I LIKE THE PLAY.
LET'S TALK ON IT.
I WAS GONNA SAY LET'S LOOK FOR
SOME LAY UPS NOW.
WE GOT TWO STRAIGHT SOLID BETS.
LET'S LOOK FOR A LAY UP TO MIX
IN HERE, A COUPLE OF LAY -- LAY
UPS, BUT LET'S GET STRATEGIC ON
HOW WE DO THIS ONE.
>> DO WE LIKE TEASING IT DOWN TO
TWO MAYBE?
WHAT DOES THAT DO FOR US?
MINUS 270?
>> I JUST DON'T KNOW, FELL
LAWS -- FELLAS.
I WOULD RATHER PUT ANDREW
WIGGINS ON THERE.
>> WHAT ABOUT FOR ONE?
>> I DON'T HATE THAT.
>> I DON'T EITHER.
>> 216.
TO THIS NO SWEAT PROMO WE HAVE
TO GET TO PLUS 400 OTHERWISE IT
IS NOT NO SWEAT.
THAT GETS US TO WHERE WE NEED TO
BE WITH TWO LEGS LEFT.
>> YOU LIKE WIGGINS 1, MADE 3?
>> I LIKE IT.
I'M JUST MAKING SURE YOU LIKE IT
>> I DON'T HATE IT AT ALL.
WIGGINS MADE 3 AND 4 OF THE LAST
FIVE AND THOSE ARE THE ONLY
GAMES HE PLAYED SINCE BEING
BACK.
HE SHOT 6, 8, 8, 4, 7.
THE VOLUME IS THERE.
I HAVE A LOT OF HISTORY BETTING
ON WIGGINS IN 3'S.
HE CASHED ME OUT IN THE FINALS.
I'M WITH IT IF YOU GUYS ARE.
>> SPICY SPONGE DROPPED IN HERE
SMART HAS BEEN TRASHED FROM 3.
1 OF 4, 3 OF 12 AND 2 OF 8.
SPICY SPONGE, TWO OF THOSE
NUMBERS YOU GAVE US ARE OVER ONE
AND A HALF.
>> HEY, YO, I'M ABOUT TO MIX
THIS UP, Y'ALL.
TAKE OUT ANDREW WIGGINS AND PUT
IN DANTE.
>> LOVE ME SOME DANTE.
>> DO YOU SEE THAT, RYAN?
>> DANTE SLEPT ON Y'ALL.
>> HONESTLY --
>> THERE IS THE FACT THAT HE WAS
PLAYING A LOT WITH PEOPLE ARE
HURT AND NOW IT IS SHORT
MINUTES, BUT HE HAS ALWAYS COME
THROUGH FOR ME.
I AM DEFINITELY WITH IT.
ESPECIALLY 1-3.
>> I'M ALL IN.
MIKE STEVE RITTER JUMPING IN
HERE AND RYAN, QUOTE, SHOUT OUT
ME SHOULD WE TEASE THIS DOWN
RIVERO.
>> THE TRUTH.
>> BOTH THOSE THINGS ARE TRUE.
>> GUYS, DANTE, I HEARD YOU.
BUT THE THING IS I HAVE BEEN
WATCHING THIS WARRIORS TEAM.
LOOK UP HIS RECENT NUMBERS, BUT
WHEN STEPH WAS OUT, DANTE WAS IN
THE OPENING LINEUP AND THEY WERE
GELLING AND WENT ON THE WIN
STREAK AT HOME.
SINCE HE WENT BACK TO THE BENCH
ROLE, DANTE HAS THRIVED.
HE HAS NOT THRIVED SO MUCH.
I THINK JORDAN POOLE WANTS TO
START.
HE IS A YOUNG PLAYER AND SHOULD
BE STARTING, BUT HE HAS TWO HALL
OF FAMERS IN STPROPBT OF HIM,
STEPH AND CLAY, AND HE IS NOT
STARTING.
DANTE THRIVES IN THAT BENCH ROLE
ESPECIALLY ON THIS WARRIORS
TEAM.
WITH THAT BEING SAID, WHAT IS
HIS POINTS NUMBERS?
>> AND JAMES WISE MAN SAYS DANTE
GETS BOARDS.
IF THIS IS THE REAL JAMES
WISEMAN.
>> SOMEBODY IS ACTUALLY A GREAT
PARLAY.
>> IT IS FINE.
>> 8 POINTS?
BRO, BRO, WHAT?
>> HERE IS ONE THING I WANT TO
KNOW.
WE DON'T HAVE TO DO A PARLAY FOR
BOTH GAMES.
IF WE WANT TO, WE CAN RUN IT.
>> WE CAN ADD ANOTHER LEG.
WE CAN ADD ONE LEG.
>> ONE LAY UP?
>> WHATEVER KYRIE'S POINTS IS.
>> HOW MANY MINUTES IS DANTE
PLAYING?
>> LOOK IT UP.
>> IS THAT EIGHT AND A HALF
POINTS?
COME ON, MAN, STOP PLAYING.
ESPECIALLY IF THE WARRIORS
GET -- MY BAD.
IF HE IS OUT THERE HE WILL BE
OUT THERE GETTING BUCKETS.
>> BY THE WAY, WE HAVE THE CHAT
IN HERE SAYING I'M A SNITCH FOR
COMING AFTER JAMES WEISMAN.
I'M TRYING TO WIN.
IF HE IS SUSPENDED FOR A YEAR
THAT BENEFITS THE CELTICS.
>> I WILL GET HIM SUSPENDED TOO.
WHAT ARE WE DOING?
>> YOU ARE VALIDATING THE FACT
THAT YOU ARE A RAT.
>> THAT'S FINE.
AT --
AT A CERTAIN POINT I HAVE TO OWN
IT.
IF THE GRAPHICS PEOPLE WILL PUT
IT ON THE SCREEN --
>> LOOK AT THIS!
>> GREG, I WANTED TO CHECK, 27
MINUTES, 26 MINUTES, 25 MINUTES
AND 18 MINUTES.
HE COVERED THE NUMBER IN HIS
LAST THREE.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT HAPPENED
AGAINST THE SUNS ON
JANUARY 10th.
I THINK THAT WAS A MAJOR
BLOWOUT.
IT SEEMS LIKE A GOOD NUMBER TO
ME.
IT HAS US AT PLUS 500 ALREADY.
WE SHOULD ASK THE CHAT.
THAT'S A PRETTY GOOD VALUE.
>> THE OTHER THING, HE DID NOT
MAKE A THREE POINTER IN THE LAST
GAME.
>> AND HE STILL HAD 11.
>> WELL, WE NEED HIM TO MAKE A
THREE POINTER IN THE PARLAY.
I JUST WANT TO SAY THIS.
THE LAST TIME HE DIDN'T MAKE A
THREE POINTER IN THE GAME, THE
NEXT GAME HE HAD FIVE.
JUST SAYING.
>> THAT'S TRUE.
>> JUST SAYING.
>> IT SEEMS LIKE THE LAST TIME
HE DIDN'T MAKE A 3 BEFORE
JANUARY 16th WAS
DECEMBER 27th.
THAT'S A LONGTIME.
>> JAMES WEISMAN SAYING SUNS'
GAME WAS A BLOWOUT AND HE KNOWS
BECAUSE HE WAS THERE.
THAT'S GOOD INFO.
>> SHOUT OUT TO YOU JAMES
WEISMAN.
AND HOW MUCH ARE YOU PUTTING ON
THE PARLAY SO WE CAN DOCUMENT
THIS.
>> NOW YOU'RE TAKING IT TOO FAR.
>> LOOK, GUYS, EMATI SAYS ONE
MORE LEG IN THE LATE GAME.
I AGREE.
I SAY WE ARE ALREADY AT PLUS
500.
LET'S GET A MINUS 1,000 LAY UP
AND SAIL.
LET'S SAIL.
>> LET'S PAUSE.
WE DON'T NEED A MINUS 1,000 WHEN
WE CAN GET KYRIE IN 29 AND A
HALF POINTS.
>> I DON'T LIKE THAT.
THE SUNS HAVE BEEN SO TERRIBLE
LATELY.
HE MAY GET 30 AND THREE -- 30 IN
THREE QUARTERS AND GET OUT OF
THERE.
>> LOOK AT THIS THOUGH.
>> LISTEN, MAN.
>> THIS IS CRAZY.
WE WENT FROM LOSING THE LAST
COUPLE WEEKS TO TRYING TO WIN A
PLUS A THOUSAND?
>> NO.
I'M NOT WITH HIM.
>> WAIT.
THIS IS WHAT WE CAN DO.
WE CAN PROBABLY BECAUSE IT IS
PLUS 1,000, TEASE DRAMOND DOWN
AND THEN WE CAN JUST SWEAT
DANTE.
>> NO.
NO.
>> WHY?
ALL WE NEED IS TO GET TO PLUS
400.
>> WE NEED A MINUS THOUSAND --
WE NEED A LAY UP TO FINISH THE
PARLAY OFF.
>> I LIKE IT.
I DON'T WANT TO USE THIS.
THIS IS TOO MUCH, MAN.
>> SPICY SPONGE SAYS, RYAN, COME
ON, BRO.
>> SPICY SPONGE IS A HATER.
SPICY SPONGE JUST JUMPS IN HERE
AND HATES.
>> I THINK HE IS HATING BECAUSE
HE WANTS TO WIN.
WE DON'T NEED TO DO ALL THIS TO
WIN.
>> HERE.
LET'S PLAY ALONG WITH -- I HAVE
MY HANDS ON THE KEYBOARD.
I'M THE CAPTAIN NOW.
>> HE GETS SO TERRITORIAL.
HE SAYS I GOT MY HANDS ON THE
KEYBOARD.
>> WE HAVE TO FIX THIS.
SOMEWAY, SOMEHOW WE HAVE TO FIX
THIS.
I SHOULD BE ABLE TO HOVER AND
TAKE OVER.
>> IS IT DOES -- IT DOESN'T EVEN
GET TO 4 PLUS WHICH IS A
PROBLEM.
>> I ADMIT THAT IS AN ISSUE.
>> I SEE A TAKE IN THE CHAT.
>> NO, BRO.
DON'T EVEN -- NOPE.
TAKE OFF THE DANTE3 AND IT MAKES
NO SENSE.
IF WE'RE GONNA BET HIS POINTS --
BRO, HE SHOOTS 3S.
LOOK AT THE NUMBERS.
>> I AGREE.
>> HE PUT UP FOUR 3'S, 6, 12,
11.
HE SHOOTS THREE'S.
>> HOLDUP.
HOLDUP.
IN THAT SAME VEIN YOU SAY HE
DIDN'T MAKE ANY ONE NIGHT AND
THE NEXT NIGHT HE IS REGGIE
MILLER, SHOULD WE JUST TAKE THE
ONE AND A HALF THREE'S?
IT IS PLUS MONEY, GREG.
>> THAT WAS GOING TO BE MY TAKE.
IF WE TAKE THE THREE'S AND THE
POINTS WE MAY AS WELL TAKE THE
PLUS MONEY FOR TWO 3'S.
>> WE HAVE A PARLAY AND WE WILL
WIN MONEY.
>> THAT STILL HAS THE POINTS.
>> WHAT POINTS?
>> I SEE FOUR.
THE FIFTH LEG WOULD BE KYRIE.
>> I THOUGHT THAT WAS GOING TO
BOOST IT UP TO A THOUSAND.
>> LEAVE THE KYRIE STUFF IN
THERE AND WE'RE GOOD AND GET OUT
OF HERE.
>> WHAT ARE WE DOING?
WE JUST HAD THE PARLAY, AND HOW
IS IT GONNA HIT?
I'M SO CONFUSED.
OH THE DRAMOND --
>> SO YOU PUT DOWN REBOUNDS -- I
GET IT.
WE HAVE TO TAKE THE UNDER OUT OF
THERE AND TALK ABOUT SOMETHING
ELSE.
>> A BYE.
WHY DO YOU THINK HE WILL GO
UNDER THE SUNS?
>> TWO REASONS.
I HAVE A PERSONAL VENDETTA
AGAINST KYRIE IRVING.
>> I DON'T WANT TO HEAR THAT.
I DON'T WANT TO HEAR IT.
TAKE IT OUT.
I DON'T WANT TO HEAR NO PERSONAL
VENDETTAS.
THAT'S NOT GONNA MAKE US NO
MONEY.
WHAT YOU NEED TO DO IS START
OVER.
>> GO TO BED AND GIVE US ONE
LAYER.
>> TRUST ME.
I AM NOT GOING TO BED UNTIL VERY
LATE TONIGHT SO YOU DON'T HAVE
TO WORRY ABOUT THAT.
WHAT IF WE DO -- LET'S GO BACK
TO REBOUNDS.
>> THIS IS LITERALLY, RYAN, YOU
SAID WE HAVE NOT WON A PARLAY IN
SO LONG AND THIS IS WHY.
WE SIT HERE AND WE HAVE WINNERS
DRAWN UP AND THEN YOU COME AND
DO YOUR PROPAGANDA.
YOU DO YOUR RYAN SWITCHEROO.
>> YOU WERE GOING TO CALL IT A
SCHTICK.
OKAY.
--
>> NOT A FAN OF THE KYRIE
UNDERPLAY.
>> D HARRIS SAYING WE DON'T CARE
ABOUT YOUR PERSONAL FEELINGS.
I DON'T CARE ABOUT YOUR PERSONAL
FEELINGS, D HARRIS.
HOW ABOUT THAT?
HOW DID THAT FEEL?
IT PROBABLY DIDN'T FEEL GOOD.
I DON'T CARE ABOUT YOU EITHER.
>> I AM OVER HERE LAUGHING AT
BAGEL AND LOX.
I'M GONNA CHOKE.
OH SNAP!  THAT'S A GOOD ONE.
>> TAKE THE MOUSE AWAY FROM THE
RAT.
>> WE SET OURSELVES UP IN A
SCENARIO.
IT IS PLUS 390.
IF WE GO AND WE TAKE A MINUS
1,000.
>> NO, NO, NO, NO.
I'M SORRY.
DRAYMOND GREEN OVER SIX IN THE
HALF REBOUNDS, NOT 6 PLUS.
LOOK AT THE ODDS WHEN YOU CHANGE
IT.
DON'T YOU LIKE ODDS?
>> ALL I'M SAYING IS THAT ALL WE
HAVE TO DO IS GET TO PLUS 400
AND THIS IS STPHO SWEAT.
IF -- THIS IS NO SWEAT.
IF WE TAKE KYRIE IN THE NEXT
GAME AND BOOM, WE ARE AT PLUS
400 AND WE CAN WRAP IT UP AND GO
HOME.
>> YEAH.
I DON'T KNOW THOUGH.
>> HOW IS IT -- OKAY.
>> WE GOT A GOOD SUGGESTION FOR
THE LOCK IN THE NEXT GAME.
ROCKY MOUNTAIN 52-80.
AYTON OVER REBOUND.
I THINK THAT IS A GOOD ONE.
>> AGAIN, --
>> I'M SORRY GO AHEAD, RYAN.
>> NO, NO, NO.
I WILL JUST DO WHAT EVERYONE
WANTS.
IT IS FUN.
>> GO TO AIDAN'S REBOUND AND
LET'S TAKE IT DOWN SLOW.
>> LET'S TAKE IT DOWN ALL THE
WAY.
WE ARE AT PLUS 491.
>> HE WILL GET SIX BOARDS.
WHAT WILL THAT DO?
>> THEY CAN'T EVEN LET ME DO
FOUR.
>> PLUS 524.
>> THERE IT IS, RYAN.
>> TO BE FAIR, WHAT CAN WE DO
HERE -- HOLD ON.
IF WE GO AND WE SAY, WELL, YOU
KNOW, PROTECT OURSELVES AND WE
GO TO SIX AND WE ARE AT PLUS 410
AND WE ARE NO SWEATING.
WE DIDN'T GO TO THE GYM TODAY
AND WE'RE NOT SWEATING.
WE'RE PRETTY DRY.
>> IT'S NOT ENOUGH FOR YOU.
>> AND NOW WE'RE PLAYING THE
PING-PONG.
DO WE HAVE IT AT SIX BOARDS?
>> IT IS GONNA GET EIGHT BOARDS
IF WE WANT TO PUT 8 AND UP.
>> IS THAT WHAT WE WANT TO DO?
>> YEAH.
JUST CHECK ON IT.
MIGHT AS WELL.
>> BRO, WHY ARE WE -- I JUST
DON'T UNDERSTAND THE FACT THAT
WE ARE GONNA LAY A WHOLE DOLLAR
OVER .5 WITH DRAYMOND.
>> WE DON'T HAVE TO.
IF WE CHANGE AYTON FROM 6 TO 8,
DO WE GET CLOSE TO THE 500?
YEAH, THAT'S PRETTY GOOD.
>> IT STILL DOESN'T MAKE SENSE.
OVER .5?
>> I AM DOWN TO KEEP IT THE WAY
IT WAS.
>> WHEN DO WE EVER GET BURNED BY
THE HOOK ON THIS SHOW?
RYAN, REMIND ME.
YOU MAY PERSONALLY GET BURNED BY
THE HOOK, BUT ON THIS SHOW, ON
OUR PARLAY, WHEN ARE WE BURNED
BY THE HOOK?
>> I THINK THERE WAS A TIME WE
BET TATUM AND HE GOT 39 AND THAT
HAPPENED RECENTLY.
>> HE'S NOT WRONG.
>> TECHNICALLY HE IS CORRECT.
OH BOY.
>> LET'S SEE WHAT THE CHAT SAYS.
DO WE WANT TO GO WITH THE HOOK?
I MEAN, EITHER WAY WE ARE IN A
GOOD SPOT.
SPICY SPONGE SAYS LET RYAN COOK.
SPICY SPONGE GOES BACK AND
FORTHWITH ME.
HOW ABOUT THIS?
I WILL CONCEDE.
ONLY BECAUSE WHO* -- WHO IS IN
HERE?
MIKE, HE IS NOT GOOD EVEN -- AND
EVEN IF YOU THINK HE DOESN'T
WANT TO BE IN PHOENIX BECAUSE
THE SUNS STINK AND THEY ARE A
BAD TEAM -FRPBGTS -- THOSE
THINGS ARE TRUE.
HE WILL STILL GET SIX REBOUNDS.
WE AGREE WITH THAT, RIGHT?
EVEN ON HIS FIRST NIGHT HE WILL
GET SIX REBOUNDS.
HE GETS THEM BY ACCIDENT.
>> LET'S GO WHAT WE HAD
ORIGINALLY.
S*EUBGDZ FOR AYTON AND SIX AND A
HALF FOR DRAYMOND GREEN.
>> I CAN SEE IT.
>> WE WILL RISE IT TO 6 AND A
HALF.
I THINK THE IDEA WE HAD IN THE
BEGINNING WE SHOULD STICK TO.
>> ALL RIGHT, GREG.
ALL RIGHT, MAN.
LOOK AT THIS.
DO WE WANT TO REVIEW IT?
>> WE CAN REVIEW IT.
>> WHAT'S THE PROBLEM?
>> I DON'T GET IT.
I REALLY DON'T.
I DO THESE SHOWS FOR YOU WEEK
AFTER --
>> WHAT IS HAPPENING IN --
HAPPEN STPH-G.
>> SOMEBODY SUSPENDED THE GAME
OR SOMEBODY IS TO THE PLAYING OR
SOMETHING?
>> THIS HAS NEVER HAPPENED.
>> WE NEED A SQUAD ROUND FOR
TONIGHT.
I KNOW LOGAN IS IN HERE
LISTENING.
I WANT TO EVALUATE SOME PLAYS AS
WE WAIT FOR THIS TO COME BACK.
LOGAN SAYS THE BULLS GAME JUST
ENDED SO THIS IS SUSPENDED.
IF YOU HAVE A LOCK, DROP IT IN
THE CHAT AND WE WILL PICK UP
OUTSIDE THE PARLAY A SQUAD RIDE
TO USE TONIGHT.
HONESTLY, A LOT OF TALK ABOUT
KYRIE AND THE SUNS WITHOUT DEVON
BOOKER.
IF WE REALLY LIKE IT, IT COULD
BE A GOOD BET BUT I WANT TO KNOW
WHAT THE CHAT HAS TO SAY.
>> WE'RE A FAMILY.
WE ARE SUSPENDED AGAIN.
>> NO.
>> WE'RE IN -- WE'RE A FAMILY
AND I TELL YOU KYRIE IRVING IS
ON MY ENEMY'S LIST.
>> LISTEN, I DON'T GIVE A -- I
DON'T GIVE TWO SCOOTS ABOUT
KYRIE EITHER.
SOME PEOPLE LIKE IT AND SO I
WON'T HATE ON THAT BECAUSE IT IS
A SINGLE BED -- BET AND A
PARLAY.
>> DO YOU KNOW WHAT THAT SOUNDS
LIKE TO BE HONEST?
>> A MAN OF THE PEOPLE?
THAT SOUNDS LIKE AN ORIGINAL MAN
OF THE PEOPLE.
MIKE ICE SAYS HE MADE IT HOT AND
SO IT IS SUCCESS 13E7DED.
>> AND THEY FIGURED OUT JAMES
WEISEN WAS IN HERE.
>> I LIKE JAMES.
>> HE WILL BE A GOOD TRADE FOR
YOU.
DRAYMOND GREEN OVER 6 AND A HALF
REBOUNDS.
>> EXCUSE ME.
THAT IS GOOD VIBES.
IF YOU NEED -- IF YOU SNEEZE,
THAT IS GOOD LUCK.
>> HAS THAT HAPPENED?
>> NEVER.
NEVER.
I GOT A IN YOU DOG AND I AM
GETTING IMMUNE TO IT.
>> IS THAT HOW THAT WORKS?
>> I WAS LIKE YOU AND I WAS
AGAINST IT, BUT I SWEAR IT IS
REAL.
>> WE ARE GETTING A LOT OF TAKES
>> I WAS NEVER AROUND DOGS AND I
WAS ANTI-DOGS BECAUSE I WAS
ALLERGIC.
>> I AM NOT ANTI-DOG.
>> I SHOULDN'T HAVE SAID THAT
PART, BUT I I WAS SKEPTICAL
BEING AROUND DOG.
>> I HAVE A DOG.
I'M NOT ANTI-DOG.
>> WHAT ARE WE TALKING ABOUT?
>> I WAS ABOUT TO SAY YOU TPAOBE
RAIL.
>> WE HAVE MIKE -- I LIKE THE K
YRIE BET.
I DON'T KNOW, MAN.
LET'S GRADE SOME OF THESE.
>> I CASE ONE CASE SLACK.
>> BEN SIMMONS OVER SEVEN AND A
HALF ASSISTS.
THAT'S A GOOD ONE.
>> I LIKE THAT TOO.
1K SLACK IS A GOOD ONE AS WELL.
SEUPLT -- SIMMONS HAD A LOT OF
ASSISTS.
ONE GAME HE HAD 10 BY HALF TIME.
I DO THINK HE WILL BLOW THE SUNS
OUT OF THE WATER.
>> IS THAT -- THAT SEEMS LIKE A
LOCK DOWN TO ME.
>> WHEN YOU ARE SAYING THAT YOU
MEAN REBOUNDS BECAUSE HE IS NOT
GOING TO SCORE.
>> THE TWO GAMES HE PLAYED WAS
TPHAO*EUB ASSISTS AND 13
ASSISTS.
I'D TAKE THE 7 AND A HALF.
>> WHO IS MY GUY?
ONE CASE SLACK.
>> GUYS, DO WE LOCK -- DID WE
LOCK IN THE PARLAY?
>> DO WE WANT ME TO READ IT ONE
MORE TIME OR THREE MORE TIMES
LIKE USUAL?
>> DO WE EVEN KNOW IF IT IS
ALIVE?
>> IT'S ALIVE.
ODDS WENT UP, BY THE WAY.
>> LET'S LOCK IT IN FOR THE
PEOPLE ONE MORE TIME.
DRAYMOND GREEN, OVER 6 AND A
HALF REBOUNDS, MARCUS SMART,
DANTE AND OVER EIGHT AND A HALF
POINTS.
DEANDREE, 6 PLUS POINTS.
>> I THINK IT WINS.
>> IN DANTE WE TRUST.
>> THE GOOD THING IS -- I WAS
GONNA SAY THE GOOD THING IS
WE'LL KNOW BY TWO HOURS FROM NOW
IF WE'RE DEAD OR NOT.
>> WE'RE GOOD.
GOOD VIBES.
>> WE'LL BE FINE.
>> AND ALSO IT IS WEES PIZZA AND
NOT PLANE PIZZA.
YOU'RE WRONG.
>> HE IS RIGHT.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT YOU ARE
TALKING ABOUT.
I DON'T WANT TO DO THIS AGAIN.
>> I THOUGHT WE WERE ALL MEN OF
THE PEOPLE.
ALL OF A DUD -- SUDDEN IT IS I
DISAGREE WITH RYAN.
>> YOU CAN'T BE A MAN IF YOU
CALL PIZZA A PLAIN PIZZA.
>> IT WAS THE FIRST COMMENT.
>> YOU'RE FORCING IT, BRO.
YOU CAN'T FORCE BEING A MAN OF
THE PEOPLE.
THE PEOPLE HAVE TO CHOOSE.
>> YOU'RE FRY -- YOU'RE TRYING
TO FORCE IT.
>> AND IF YOU'RE CALLING ME A
RAT, NEW YORK RATS LOVE
THEMSELVES SOME PIZZA.
WOULDN'T I KNOW?
ALL OF A SUDDEN I AM USING THE
SLANDER.
>> RATS LOVE CHEESE.
DAMN RIGHT THEY LIKE PIZZA.
THEY DON'T LIKE PLAIN PIZZA.
DO YOU THINK A RAT WILL EAT A
PIECE OF DOUGH WITH SAUCE ON IT?
I'M GETTING MAD.
>> CALL IT CHEESE PIZZA.
IT IS ALREADY -- THE CHEESE IS
ALREADY ON.
>> I'VE NEVER SEEN HIM MAD
BEFORE.
IT HAS TO STOP.
>> I'LL ORDER IT NEXT TIME.
>> MY MAN EMBIID IS FROM CHICAGO
AND THEY KNOW ABOUT PIZZA OUT
THERE.
>> THEY KNOW ABOUT HOT DOGS.
THEY DON'T KNOW ABOUT PIZZA.
>> YOU ARE OUT OF LINE AND I AM
NOT GOING TO LISTEN TO IT.
>> WE HAVE A SHOW COMING UP
SOON.
I WAS CHASING PIZZA IN NEW YORK,
DEBATABLE.
IT IS VERY DEBATABLE.
>> IF YOU ARE GOING TO SBARRO.
IF YOU ARE GOING TO 7-LEN.
>> WHAT?
YOU THINK I AM THAT TYPE OF GUY?
>> THIS IS THE PIZZA CAPITAL OF
THE WORLD.
I DON'T KNOW WHERE YOU ARE
GOING.
>> IF WE ARE GOING TO HAVE A
DEEP DISH TOGETHER, BE READY.
>> JALEN BROWN OUT TONIGHT.
>> THAT'S BIG.
>> DOES IT DO ANYTHING TO THE
PARLAY.
IT IS PROBABLY A GOOD THING.
>> I'M GONNA BE HONEST.
HAVE I BEEN TO NEW YORK A COUPLE
TIMES AND TASTED FEE SWRAU AND
NOT -- PIZZA AND NOT IMPRESSED.
>> TO BE HONEST, THE PIZZA IS
BETTER IN NEW JERSEY ANYWAY.
>> IT IS FINISH, FLIMSY PIZZA.
>> YOUR PIZZA IS LASAGNA.
>> WE WILL HAVE TO GET OFF THE
SHOW.
>> RYAN.
READ THE PARLAY ONE MORE TIME.
LET'S TAKE THIS OFFLINE.
LET'S TAKE THIS DEBATE OFFLINE.
>> DRAYMOND GREEN OVER SECONDS
AND A HALF REBOUNDS AND MARCUS
SMART MADE PLUS 3.
DANTE SOFR 1 AND A HALF MADE
THREE'S.
DANTE -- FIVE LEGS PLUS 520.
>> RYAN, THEY ARE TRYING TO SEND
YOU TO SACRAMENTO.
>> DON'T DO THAT.
DON'T DO THAT, MAN.
THAT'S LIKE SENDING ME TO TULSA,
OKLAHOMA.
WHAT'S THERE?
>> I WENT TO PIZZA.
NAH, I WENT TO THE ORIGINAL, YOU
FEEL ME?
>> I LOVE JEFF, MAN.
HE IS A GREAT DUDE AND HE IS
SAYING DEEP DISH PIZZA AND
POTPIE.
DEEP DISH PIZZA WAS MADE FOR
TOURISTS TO EAT AT THE PLACES WE
DON'T WANT TO EAT.
WE GET OUR THIN CRUST PIZZA AND
IF YOU HAVE HATING TAKES ON THAT
I WILL NOT DEFEND IT.
CHICAGO'S THIN CRUST PIZZA IS
UNEQUIVOCALLY BETTER THAN THE
GARBAGE IN NEW YORK.
>> HEY RYAN, I GUARANTEE YOU, I
TRIPLE WHAMMY, DOUBLE DOG YOU
SACRAMENTO GOT BETTER PIZZA THAN
NEW YORK.
>> SACRAMENTO?
>> SACRAMENTO GOT BETTER PIZZA
THAN NEW YORK.
>> DO THEY EVEN KNOW -- DO THEY
EVEN KNOW WHAT PIZZA IS IN
SACRAMENTO.
>> IT'S CALIFORNIA.
IT IS CALIFORNIA, BRO, ONE OF
THE BEST STATES TO EVER LIVE IN.
>> LISTEN.
HAVE I NO BEEF WITH CALIFORNIA.
I HAVE BEEF WITH SACRAMENTO.
THERE IS NOTHING IN SACRAMENTO.
>> YOU HAVE TO REALIZE,
SACRAMENTO IS THE CAPITAL OF ONE
OF THE BEST STATES IN THE UNITED
STATES.
>> OKAY.
LISTEN.
TALLAHASSEE IS THE CAPITAL --
>> THE BEST.
THE BEST IN THE UNITED STATES.
>> OKAY.
>> I CAN'T SAY [EXCLAW TIFF] ON
THE SHOW, BUT THAT'S
[EXPLETIVE].
>> PRODUCER MAX WANTED ME TO SAY
THAT SACRAMENTO IS LIKE THE
JERSEY.
OAKLAND IS LIKE THE JERSEY.
>> LISTEN.
SHOUT OUT TO JAYBLOW57.
HE SAID WE NEED IT TO HIT TO
AFFORD PIZZA.
>> THAT'S TRUE.
LISTEN, DUDE, TALLAHASSEE IS THE
CAPITAL OF FLORIDA.
NOBODY GOES TO TALLAHASSEE.
>> YOU JUST SAID SACRAMENTO IS
IN WASHINGTON STATE.
>> HE DOESN'T KNOW GEE KWROEG
TKPWRAU -- GEOGRAPHY.
>> HE GETS IT.
IT IS JUST THAT YOU DRIVE
THROUGH SACRAMENTO.
THAT'S IT.
YOU DON'T STOP.
IF YOU STOP, YOU ARE LOW ON GAS.
>> SACRAMENTO IS THE HEART OF
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA.
IT IS THE HEART OF IT.
>> SAN FRANCISCO IS THE HEART OF
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA.
>> HERE IS WHAT WE ARE GOING TO
DO.
WE WILL ALL PUT THE MONEY ON THE
PARLAY AND THEN WE WILL ALL GET
FLIGHTS TO SACRAMENTO AND THEN
ALL HAVE A GOOD TIME.
>> I CAN'T ARGUE.
FRAN -- SAN FRANCISCO IS A GREAT
PLACE TO BE.
>> AS OUR FEAR -- FEARLESS
LEADER WOULD SAY, I KNOW FALL --
I KNOW PAUL.
>> SAN FRANCISCO'S CLAM CHOWDER
IS DOING DANCES AROUND BOSTON'S
CLAM CHOWDER.
BUT WE DON'T HAVE TO GO THERE.
WE DON'T HAVE TO GO THERE.
ONE THING I DO KNOW IS
SACRAMENTO'S PIZZA IS 10 TIMES
BETTER THAN NEW YORK'S PIZZA.
WE CAN DO TASTE TESTS, RYAN.
WE CAN SEND YOU OUT TO
SACRAMENTO AND TASTE TEST.
FIRST, SENDING ME TO SACRAMENTO
SOUNDS LIKE PUNISHMENT.
IF WE NEED TO DO IT, THEN WE'LL
DO.
IT IT IS WHAT IT IS.
>> WILL -- WELL, WE GOT A GOOD
PARLAY AND WE GOT THE PIZZA TAKE
BACK IN HERE AND NOW IT IS JUST
TIME TO WIN.
>> TIME TO WIN.
LET'S GET OUT OF HERE.
RYAN, YOU SEE THE PARLAY AND I
WON'T HAVE THEM READ IT AGAIN.
A TAKE A SCREENSHOT OF IT.
RIDE WITH US BECAUSE WE'RE GONNA
WIN.
I'M FEELING THE GOOD VIBES.
LET'S GET OUT OF HERE BECAUSE
IT'S SOME MONEY TO BE MADE.
I AM GREG IVY AND THE MAN NEXT
TO ME IS MB.
HE IS THE WHISPER OF THE
BLEACHER REPORT APP.
NEXT TO HIM IS THE MAN I'M
BEEFING WITH, BUT THE MAN I HAVE
MAD LOVE FOR, PRODUCER RYAN.
PRODUCER RYAN THINKS HE IS A MAN
OF THE PEOPLE, BUT WE'RE STILL
WORKING ON THAT.
>> DUDE, I'M SHOCKED THEY DIDN'T
TOSS A RATE OVER MY FACE.
>> YOU JUST WANT THEM TO DO IT.
>> NO.
THEY DID IT ENOUGH TIMES.
IT WAS BEATING A DEAD HORSE.
>> HE IS LIKE REALLY WANTING YOU
TO PUT -- HE REALLY WANTS YOU TO
DO IT.
PROVIDE DEUCER RYAN -- PRODUCER
RYAN AND MY NAME IS GREG.
WE UP OUT OF HERE.
PEACE!